I saw you a couple of weeks ago and you
mentioned to me that you had been on
this insane trip and I'm just curious we
didn't get a chance to talk about it but
where did you go oh yeah because we were
in New York yes
wearing heels a similar sort of God
which is a little bit foreign to me at
the moment because I've been in
Patagonia in Chile and Patagonia I've
never ever been there I've heard I've
heard it's unworldly it's deep south
hemisphere beautiful mountains and it's
sort of Lord of the Rings ask and I
rivers and glaciers and lots of Chileans
and horse races no and what were you
there for was it just a sightsee or no
we'd finished I'd wrap this show that I
was on I thought them the natural thing
to do is rather than go and get my
chakras realigned which a lot of people
seem to do after yes that's a very la
Fiona can you get your chakras realign
yeah yes exactly
um this breed of humans so I thought now
I need to go and get myself plugged into
some some wild invention so entered an
80 kilometer endurance race on on on
horseback 80 kilometers on horseback
yeah yeah that's intense how long does
it take to ride 80 kilometers I mean it
would take me several months yeah it
would take me a while I would ride very
slowly on a pony you get your little
Shetland yeah exactly maybe would be
dragging along I would go very slowly
that sounds like you're riding hard if
you're going 80 kilometres yeah when did
one day yeah well it's you start at nine
o'clock in the morning and then you end
at five in the afternoon and so you do
three vet checks to make sure the horses
are safe and well unhealthy they don't
really mind whether you're healthy or
not right they sort of just check the
horses and and then all going well you
trudge off across this incredible
terrain and I honestly thought that
somebody had dropped acid in my tea
because I had travelled you know 24
hours and then it was introduced this
beautiful horse and got to know him for
maybe two days and then literally just
canted across this extraordinary terrine
so I was sort of giggling the whole way
because the whole thing was so bizarre I
don't even know how you would hear about
this trip I mean this sounds like
something like an incredible it first of
all it sounds wait
I would difficult for me and I like like
I've always wanted one of those bicycle
trips where you ride like 15 feet and
then they they take out an incredible
meal like a van pulls up yeah
and they give you French food and then
you go 20 feet and then a Mexican food
you know it's just one of those sort of
food yeah the great thing about South
America says amazing wine yeah there is
amazing wine but I had some a couple of
very good friends and they run safaris
because I went up to Argentina
afterwards one is called the company's
called Bagwell and the other one is Jaco
tengo and they both run safaris down in
South America and Mongolia should any of
you choose to go yeah and they're
extraordinary men from almost like
another era and they happily chaperoned
me around and I'm a capable horse woman
and I love being outside and anything to
get me really away from you know when
you're working on a show for seven
months and you were sort of in the
studio as you know yes you get a little
bit of cabin fever and well at least I
have this expansive view I know it's you
know what I know what you mean you have
these fantasies about getting away you
actually brought a picture I think this
is it's absolutely stunning it does look
like Lord of the Rings yeah looks like
you're gling gloor coming to give me the
ring of gore bore